[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
adam carolla has a new show it's called
uh
truth yeller the daily wire with adam
carolla he'll be joined by comedic
legends like jay leno rob riggle william
shatner uh hilarious stand up specials
first episode just premiered on the
daily wire this past friday we spoke
with adam carolla and uh i asked him if
he'd ever been fired from a job
uh
well i i mean it's it's a little murky
these days uh but i you know my radio
format my radio station i was on when i
was doing morning radio when i took over
for howard stern on the west coast
flip formats in 09
so i wasn't really fired but i didn't
have a place to go monday morning so
i'll
i'll i'll i'll take that as firing but
when you think back on that you're
replacing howard stern
was there
any part of you that said what am i
doing
well you know when i was replacing
howard stern and and i was successful
and had a bunch of affiliates and was
number one in a lot of markets and and
did it for over three years
people would say to me all the time like
wow you're replacing howard stern
and
i had an answer for him
and also i had a history i had done
stern show 50 times i'd sat in with him
all the time i used to sit in artie's
chair and you know do all four hours and
stuff like that
so
to many stern was the great and powerful
oz you know to me
i kind of knew him as a friend and a
almost a colleague and a guy and i felt
like i'd been in the ring and sparred
with the champ so many times that i felt
like oh yeah i feel confident about this
uh but i said when people said you know
you're replacing howard stern
aren't you intimidated and i said
you know brad pitt and jennifer aniston
used to be married and then they got
divorced
and if somebody said would you like to
date jennifer aniston your first thought
might be well i don't know if i look as
good as brad pitt with my shirt off
but you'd be a fool not to say yes
and that's the way i approached it
would you date brad pitt
that's kind of what i was saying i'm
glad you're able to
should you ever apologize for a joke
i always think you should apologize on a
macro level and not a micro level so you
know sometimes with me people go oh he
never apologizes i i apologize to my
daughter all the time i would apologize
to my wife i apologize to my dad my mom
like my sister like
friends like people i'd
done something wrong to on a sort of
micro level you don't want to be the
person that just doesn't apologize you
know if you
walk into a starbucks and you cut in
front of somebody in line and they say
excuse me apologize go oh sorry i didn't
see you you know but when you tell a
joke and you sort of put it out to the
world
and the mob comes after you then don't
apologize to the mob
apologize to the man
explain the new show that you're doing
uh the daily wire has a new comedy show
it's called truth yeller and yet uh jay
leno is your first guest william shatner
rob riggle or so what what is the goal
with this show
well it's a series of stand-up specials
hour-long stand-up specials it's on the
daily wire
um
for me i'm a comedian i want to do a
stand-up special there's no real play
for me at netflix or hbo hollywood has
kind of
gotten ultra awoke and i'm on the wrong
side of history according to them so
i went somewhere that would embrace me
and that was the daily wire
it's a traditional stand-up special at
the beginning i do about 15 or 20
minutes a stand at the beginning then
the guest comes out
guest does a little bit of stand up
we'll do an interview
we'll play some games and at the end we
do a full improv game where before the
show we'll hand out balls to the
audience they'll write one word on it
it'll go into a bingo hopper the guest
will pull it out say the one word
whatever the one word is we need to do
or i need to do a stand up routine on it
so it's improv it's stand-ups kind of a
hybrid
thing it's a good show we've done two so
far that really turned out great and
it's just exciting to kind of mess with
the format a little bit how dangerous of
a time is it for comedians
well it's dangerous if you're a comedian
and you host the bachelor
or you're comedian and you work for espn
or you know if you have a mothership
it's very dangerous if your mothership
is
hbo or abc
or cnn or you're going to get screwed
you're not going to be able to go out do
a set that night and then come back to
work in the morning someone's gonna film
you
if you don't really have a mothership if
you could be sort of autonomous
uh like i am then there's no danger
whatsoever the real danger is when
you're getting a paycheck from disney
and disney can cut you off
give me the uh person that you'd love to
interview in this format
well dan i feel like you would make a
fetching
uh then uh i'll go with lee iacocca is
he still alive no he's not
and i'm out of answers how about an
athlete
um yeah i mean like someone like charles
barkley would be awesome
up there you know or maybe aaron rodgers
or you know somebody who was kind of in
the zeitgeist someone who had something
to say someone who had you know
aspirations beyond what they did on the
court or the playing field
guys guys like that
tom brady lebron james
yeah although i feel like tom brady and
lebron i think tom would be a little
careful about what he was saying lebron
would have a kind of hard angle to what
he was saying they they would all be
welcome of course but
to me i
i feel
i feel like the uh round mount of
rebound would probably be my my choice
and i'm sure you've been around people
i'm always fascinated that if i'm around
a stand-up comedian or i'm around
somebody who is just
funny
that doesn't mean that the person who is
just funny could be a stand-up comedian
and sometimes that stand-up comedian is
not good at just being funny in the room
does that make sense to you
yeah i think you know to to bring it to
your world
i always thought being funny is like
saying that guy's athletic you know what
i mean but what's his sport you know
where's the training you know you know
what is the discipline you know
comedy is kind of that way you know
being generically funny is like saying
oh that guy's a really good athlete
you know but but but you don't get paid
unless you pick a sport you know and
then you focus on it and you get good at
it stand up you know late night host
morning radio
taking that funny that athleticism and
then directing it and training it
because you know
we we all remember you guys that were
just great natural athletes but you
gotta you gotta train you gotta study
the game film
going back to tom brady and back to
back to guys like brady i know guys who
are really funny but they couldn't
really get get it out on stage you know
just like that guy's a great athlete but
he's not again and then other guys would
play beyond their ability or there were
gamers you know they showed up in those
real clutch moments and got that hit
in the ninth inning so
sports and comedy are kind of kind of
analogous in in that in that regard but
who is the funniest comedian who's not
doing his stand-up bit where you're just
sitting around at dinner
and and he just makes you laugh where it
hurts
you know i always say like people say to
me like who's the funniest guy you know
adam and i go you don't know that guy's
name
that's that's the problem you know
they're guys i mean guys like jimmy
kimmel are funny guys
but i know guys that are technically
funnier
but they don't have his work ethic they
don't have his focus they don't have his
drive they don't have his 10 000 hours
of experience then you know just like
you know jerry rice and jerry porter you
know jerry porter
i i i do think about this because i know
jerry i i was at the raiders training
camp when jerry porter it was a wideout
for the raiders and someone else after
that he was an amazing phenomenal
athlete jerry porter was taller faster
and had bigger hands than jerry rice but
but jerry rice is going to the hall of
fame and jerry porter isn't and that's
not because jerry rice is a better
athlete than jerry porter
is this the first jerry porter reference
on the show paulie uh in at least a
decade okay that's what i that's what i
thought uh david
why i challenge you dan to watch jerry
porter and try it yourself
when he made a catch and he got knocked
down and he was on his back in the nfl
he could get up without using his hand
from his back he would kick look it up
everyone look it up he would kick his
heels to the side hold the ball on his
chest and just rise
he's a six three 230 pound guy in full
pads who would just pop up he was a
credible athlete
and it really meant nothing to his
ability to catch a pass
no it didn't i think it freaked the
defense
i've been around david spade before and
and so sandler
uh chris rock the whole group when
they're around schneider spade's the
funniest guy
and and they acknowledge it rock and
sandler say
spade is the funniest guy now if i put
that you know to a question for people
they would not pick david spade over
sandler or chris rock or chris farley
you know there's just something about
the sneaky throwaway line
that i love see i was never
a robin williams fan because it it was
so
there
where i want to find it i don't want it
to find me
uh right
but you know you have some community you
know sam kennison was there right in
front of you uh a lot of great guys i
just love the the humor where they tap
you on the shoulder
where do you stand with that yeah no i'm
i'm i'm with you i i feel the same way
about lingerie
i i just i
i mean i don't need all the heels and
all the straps and all the
uh of the tassels i i just like uh nice
bra and panties and it's go time i don't
want to be hit in the face
i don't want to get hit in the face
either with it
[Laughter]
well good luck with it it's great to
talk to you again i i appreciate it
always good talk to you dan adam carolla
radio personality comedian actor
podcaster host of the adam corolla show
and his new show on the daily wire it's
called truth yeller